[Musique]
j'irais cueillir pour tous les bouquets
de
muget si tu m'aimes Au joli mois de
Puissiez-vous vouloir lire tout le Plus
Bel arc-en-ciel
cy si tu m'aimes Au Moi du Grand
Soleil croyais Au moins en ma
fie cathy j'allume feux de ta
vie cathy si tu croyais Au moins en
notre
amour
j'allume tout le
jour
pourquoi t'appeler je
cathy toi que ce jour Je
vis dans ta Belle robe d'or
Gandy
pourquoi plus pourquoi
Après je te pleure Au ma
Caty Je grabai pour toi mes Plus jolis
sonnets cathy si tu m'aimes Au Jolie
Moi
de j'irais écrire la-haut notre amour
dans le
ciel Kathy si tu m'aimer Au moin du
Super
Soleil Kathy si tu croyais Au moins en
maman
cathy j'allume feux de ta
vie cathy si tu croyais Au moins en
notre
amour
j'allume toute la journée
kti
Katy oui toi
[Musique]
Je t'aime si tu
Je t'aime si tu m'aimes
si tu
[Musique]
m'aime